Donald Trump held an event yesterday at
Club 45 which I guess the renaming club
47 because they want Trump to be the
47th president or something this was
such a confusing event during which
Donald Trump visibly struggles to drink
water at one point it's really weird he
takes questions from children and still
can't answer them in any sensible way I
don't know what the hell this guy is
doing but he is incredibly desperate for
relevance he's desperate for sycophants
to suck up to him which I guess he
doesn't feel Fox News and Wall Street
Journal are doing anymore to the degree
that he wants let's look at this this
first clip
Trump takes a question from a kid who's
wearing a trump one shirt and remember
the right is worried that the left is
indoctrinating children think about that
as you listen to this
uh hello Mr President I love that shirt
it's so beautiful oh thank you he's got
to share Trump one
[Music]
they're cheering that they are teaching
a kid to believe things that simply
aren't true after you become the 47th
president what are you gonna do to stop
the war in Ukraine yeah so I would
literally start calling not from the day
I took over but from the night I won and
I called two people two people you know
the two people are Putin right your
opportunities and zelinski zielinski
and I'd say we're gonna meet we're gonna
that's how we would say he would get on
the phone and he'll go we're gonna meet
and I would I I guarantee I could work
that uh oh man I guarantee I know
exactly what I'd say by the way I know
exactly I tell one guy this and I tell
one guy that and I say you better make a
deal Trump's foreign policy ideas
extremely convincing to nine-year-olds I
think that that if if there's any big uh
ringing endorsement there's any bigger
ringing endorsement I can't think of one
um here's another really crazy one this
guy is almost in tears it really seems
like Trump is taking questions from
random people which is totally fine I
actually think it would be imagine if a
president more regularly took questions
from random people I think that that's
great the problem is these people are
such delusional sycophants
president Trump I'd like to say it's a
great honor to be in the same room with
you by the way for all I know this isn't
a random person and it's like some
fundraising guy or who knows it's my
honor
and also I'd also like to thank you
for your sacrifice yeah to the people of
this country thank you really a martyr
who gave up his great life to help us
burning us people don't understand you
had it made in the shade
and you stuck your neck out for us
that's true
[Applause]
oh dear God what this is this is the
United States in 2023
this is the front runner to be the
Republican nominee for the presidency of
the United States Trump then pulling out
his famous n-word rant which he just
loves nuclear is so devastating that we
don't even want to talk about it and
that was a word that was never supposed
to be mentioned
give two n-words neither of which should
ever be mentioned I said that once I
said oh what a terrible thing to say no
you have two n-words you know what the
one is but the other is the nuclear word
not supposed to ever be mentioned ever
ever ever
right but Trump's gonna say the n-word
for us I guess when he talks to Putin as
he likes to say
um no Trump event is a complete without
Trump complaining about the 2020
election which is now uh closing in on
three years ago and indeed he did
there's no way you could lose the
election and we got close to 75 million
votes and that's only what they agreed
to that's only what they say it's much
higher than that but they agree to it so
we got
based on that we get 12 million more
votes right
and we lost I always here here the
whisker there and you know when you look
oh Pennsylvania I guess he's at least
admitting he lost maybe how about
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania was over at 10
o'clock and then all of a sudden they
had a large drop a dump yeah by the way
did you notice he's no longer saying
dump he's now saying drop now these
people are really uh it's so sad it's so
sad I mean there's no way so anyway
Trump bemoaning that election that just
got away it just got away from him
really projecting Incredible strength
with winding three years on Trump then
is asked a question by Ashton who I
guess is like a young reporter a young
Republican reporter
and he can't even answer these these
softball questions in a way that makes
sense hi Mr President my name is Ashton
I'm the Press
the president very impressive precious
yes yes so good as the club and as young
people what is the Strategic campaign
messaging to reach Millennials in
Tennessee
well I look I said I have one little
phrase that I think became the most
powerful phrase in the history of
politics and maybe
in any country you know what the phrase
is make America great again
that's gonna be his messaging to Young
People by the way it's the same
messaging that got him almost no youth
vote in 2016 and almost no youth vote in
2020. that's his message you go into
details and you know what the details
because we've been talking about them
the whole night
make America great again another one
America first we put America first right
they're putting them that's really going
to resonate with Gen Z you can just tell
um at another point a completely
indoctrinated Super Fan of trump says
what can we do to fight for you what can
we do and Trump says I need your undying
support this is literally a cult it it
meets all of the requirements of a cult
thank you very much so my question is
since you're fighting for us what do you
want us to do to fight for you
[Applause]
support your support and not even
monetary support I mean what we need is
your absolute undying support undying
and we have other places throughout the
country where the spirit we've never
seen Spirit like we see it right now and
I think Donnie that spirit that support
uh and we can't be stopped and once
we're there we're going to fix this
country yep he's going to fix it as soon
as he gets a shot I mean okay he had
four years and he made the country worse
in so many ways but this time you can
believe him this time he really is going
to fix it someone in the audience wanted
Trump to weigh in on whether a T and T
should be dismantled which is not
exactly small government Behavior it's
not exactly the lightest Touch of
Regulation that Republicans claim to
want but
um DirecTV dropped Newsmax and so now
what about dismantling a t thank you
yeah
1982 a t was dismantled because it
became too big for its bridges at T
subsidiary DirecTV just banned Newsmax
yeah broadcasting is it time to
dismantle at T again because it's
getting too big for its printers yeah
the small government crowd that is
against regulation is calling for the
government to destroy a business thank
you sir at T is a lousy company it's
highly over levered it's run by radical
left people honestly it's doing so badly
you know normally you dismantle when
they're doing so well ATT is doing badly
they got rid of uh they took it and
DirecTV which I guess they own and they
got rid of nismix and hopefully they'll
put it back and oan also oen was
fantastic and still was fantastic but
it's a struggle for them because they're
being de-platformed they've de-platform
me and now they're all begging for me to
come back you know why because they're
dying out there without us
that's why truth is so good that's why
truth is so good but you know what I
mean is like a lousy company it's
leveraged to the hilt it uh it's doing
very poorly and yet they get rid of a
Newsmax and an oan who actually both got
very good ratings and I think there's a
lot of pressure being put on ATT dropped
you know their stock since that time
yeah the guy in the crowd is all is very
much aware of that
um so just a completely unhinged event
in every single way there was the most
interesting moment was where Donald
Trump seemed to acknowledge something I
said yesterday which is some of the
people that are getting into this race
against Trump which is really just Nikki
Haley it may be less about winning than
about auditioning to be Trump's VP and
Trump seems to be saying exactly that a
lot of people are right now auditioning
you know that a lot of people a lot of
people that are running at one percent
two percent three percent no percent
we have a couple that are joining
they're at no percent
I say I wonder what they're doing I
think they're auctioning right now for
they're auditioning right now auctioning
they're auctioning uh no try I don't
think Trump's wrong and in fact I think
this is one of the possibilities when it
comes to Nikki Haley
um as to why she is not drawing a single
policy distinction with Trump so there
it is Trump addressing supporters and
and taking questions good for him for
taking questions it's just the questions
are insane and the answers are even
crazier that's the only downside but
it's a beautiful thing I think to take
questions from supporters uh let's now
focus in on the DeSantis part plastic
it's everywhere we look and not enough
is being done about it 100 billion
plastic bags are used and thrown away
every year here's something super simple
you can do to reduce plastic and help
the planet a little bit our sponsor hold
on bags is the company making plastic
free trash bags and zip seal kitchen
bags they're just as strong and high
quality as the plastic bags you're used
to you hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single-use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com Pacman and
you'll get 20 off with code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below